it's a very sad story students will hold
a vigil tonight to honor former
University of Utah classmate Mackenzie
Luwak as details emerge about her
suspected killer 31 year old EULA a
jockey was arrested Friday
police found remains matching loic's DNA
in his backyard Jonathan Vigliotti is
outside the suspect Salt Lake City home
Jonathan what happens now and good
morning to tony jaa he will be arraigned
later this week as you mentioned were
outside his home where the remains of
Mackenzie looook were found and where
there is this small memorial prosecutors
are now looking through all of the
evidence that police gathered here but
ultimately this falls into the DA's
hands as they decide whether or not to
pursue the death penalty all of this as
we're learning more about this suspects
troubling past investigators spent the
weekend gathering more evidence at the
home of a EULA Jaheim who's expected to
be charged with Mackenzie Lewis murder
there's extensive investigation
follow-up that needs to be done and we
will proceed I mean it's not over right
now days earlier they found loic's
charred remains and belongings in a
jahi's backyard police say there is
currently no other person of interest in
the case still we want to know if he
acted alone or if there were people that
helped him along the way
police are also sharing details about a
jahi's past including a rape accusation
in northern Utah five years ago the
victim declined to pursue charges a
construction contractor has also come
for saying he turned down a job from a
Jahi back in April after a jaw he asked
him for a soundproof room with hooks in
the concrete walls and a fingerprint
lock it was adamant about getting it
done really fast and money was no object
looook was last seen on surveillance
video at the Salt Lake City Airport two
weeks ago investigators say they used
phone location data to place both a Jahi
and looook in the park where she was
dropped off by a rideshare looook was a
senior at the University of Utah
majoring in kinesiology in an online
post her sorority sister said they're
reflecting on the lasting impact she
made on the lives of her family members
friends and sisters a memorial has gone
up on campus this is just
then she didn't deserve it nobody
deserves that a Jah he describes himself
online as an IT specialist we know that
he signed up for the National Guard but
he never showed up for training there
are reports that the two met each other
on an online dating site but police are
not commenting we also don't know the
motive here we've reached out to the
suspects attorney she has not commented
Anthony so many questions still about
this fatal connection Jonathan thank you